I've ever seen the the Evergreen videos
from the Brett Weinstein situation not
really what what did he call that oh I
forgot he has a name for it a little
while ago I don't so evergreen college
but you know it was about lying I really
so I'm gonna give you the simplified
version because I'm not gonna be call
everything perfectly but Brett was a
professor his wife was a professor and
he had there's this holiday where it's
called like a day without black people
or something where all the minorities
leave to show you how important they are
and how you know they're taken for
granted okay so this year they said
we're going to the opposite all the
white people have to leave and Brett's
response was like well you can't force
people to do something if you choose to
leave to make a point that's acceptable
right so they started calling him a
racist and all these other things and
then this big scandal breaks out I don't
I don't know exactly you know I did a
documentary on a couple years ago so
it's over on the SCN our channel but
basically you have these viral clips in
one of them the school of President or
administrator whatever okay it's talking
with his hands and then someone starts
complying they're talking with your
hands as racist so no like put your
hands down put your hands down and he
puts his hands down and then they all
start laughing at them it was fake
they're just a bunch it's a it's a it's
it's a it's a river full of piranhas man
they're it's it's the New Age trolling
it's starting to hit reality I think
it's it's almost like spilling out of
the interval it really is a cult you
know but as it becomes more and more
mainstream I just call it a religion
it's literally called intersectional ism
right it's this these ideas ideology of
you know what only white people are
racist that's clearly clearly a
fundamentalist fanatic view of the world
right like these people are so man
someone told me today that minorities
can't be racist what they're like it's
not that's not a thing they can't be
racist so basically I can't be racist I
guess so I would it be a little berries
according to reddit they changed this
apparently but they briefly said that
you can mock majority groups okay yeah
so so if if we do the show from Japan
we're allowed to say whatever we want
about Japanese people yeah like the
worst imaginable things it's like the
worst because I don't like that Oh
I don't want to talk bad about anyone
that's just it's not the type of person
I am i I don't like when people complain
I want to move forward I want to like I
whenever someone's complaining I'm like
well what are you gonna do about it
and they don't have an answer I'm like
I'm done with this conversation then
yeah you know unless you have an idea or
you want to move forward talk to this
person who's pissing you off like
whatever it is I'm sick of it we are we
are dating you know I was gonna say
we're so close but now we're in it men
think we are in it you're a large
portion of our government is run by a
religious sect yep and they have sin and
confession you know and - right yeah
acolytes preachers yep flagellation and
I remember I was talking to a friend
like three years ago
mm-hmm three years ago this was before
if you're not familiar Peter Bogosian
James Lindsey and Helen pluck Rose
they're the Sokol squared individuals
this is big hoax admitted on this
feminist um publication but they had
been talking about intersectionality is
a religion it's a non-theistic religion
and you can check out their work but
I've been talking to this to a talk
about this to a friend of mine and I
mentioned that I thought it was a cult
and this is three years ago mind you so
it wasn't as nearly as prominent as it's
become today okay and they asked me like
no it's not are there like some is
someone you know like is there a leader
and I'm like there are leaders of like
different groups and yeah I would say
there are leaders you don't necessarily
need to have a like specific leader
although you know we went we had a big
argument about what a cult is and you
know some people argue you do but I'm
like the point is it's a fanatic
ideology that follows very similarly to
how cults work love-bombing
shame exile preachers who can who can
you know it's it's it's almost religious
no look there's that joke what's the
difference being the cult in a religion
and it's you know the size how many
people a good pointer to it it's a it's
a cult until you hit a certain amount of
people then you get the tax exemption
technically it's not true no I know yeah
there's there's actually no about very
specific things that religions don't do
that cult to do I was actually reading
about this and so it's a religion yeah
it's a straight-up religion yeah like
Marxism thing like a lot of the black
lives matter leaders are coming out as
Marxist and it's like you know Karl Marx
was a incredible racist yeah and I
tweeted that earlier today and someone
actually said to me you know that's
that's how it was back then you can't
you can't shame someone for the way you
know things that were normal in the past
and it's that's exactly what they're
doing for the entire history of what
we've got going on right now where is
your mind
yeah video how do you reconcile they
don't they don't want to hear these kind
of things they just want to screech and
be in the cult where they're accepted in
their cult they they found a community
that takes a little effort yep exactly
a little ayrton you show up and they
have a little little little potluck and
and we're living in a world that
requires little effort yeah compared
comparatively you know to the past you
know if you really want to survive you
can't do it by doing having little
effort you got to be really lucky you
got to be really lucky to have a life
that requires little effort but if you
want to do something you got to get out
and work for it everything's really not
not if you're in that cult because
that's easy everything's relative maybe
you're right absolutely so you know I I
have a friend who long time ago was
talking to me about there's like the way
he described it was there's two classes
of people okay they tell you that
there's like there's a lower class of
middle class upper class whatever he's
like no there's two there's people who
have broken the barrier to where they
will never want for anything and they go
through an accidental crisis and these
are the ultra-wealthy and then there's
everyone else who lives in a relative
state of comfort and is constantly
striving to survive though the way it's
it's the analogy is that if you stand
still you're on a treadmill and if you
stand still you're moving backwards if
you walk you're staying where you are
you have to run to try and move forward
yep okay so let's see that yeah so you
basically have two classes of people
most people the 99.99% are all in the
treadmill and they're all running and
this includes people who have hundreds
of thousands of dollars and make
hundreds of thousands of dollars per
year okay because they don't have
independent wealth and then you go you
go down and even the poorest people
everybody's
the treadmill running to try and get
forward some people are just laying down
and they roll backwards yeah and then
they get mad they're far behind if I but
I should be allowed to sit that's a
different argument but there are people
who've finally made to the end of the
treadmill and then they go through an
existential crisis isn't my buddy told
me because he ended up making you know
millions of dollars off some product he
invented when he was really young okay
and then all of a sudden it's like
nothing matters what do you do everybody
wants and he accomplished his goal and
so I think what what what these people
today don't realize there will always be
poverty it's quite literally impossible
to get rid of poverty it's a it's it's
just the the definition of what poverty
is could you imagine you know somebody
who makes ten thousand dollars a year
today in America is considered poor
could you imagine that living standard
120 years ago no it's like the ultra
wealthy could you imagine like go back
200 years and people are walking around
like they're riding horses and the
horses are like pooping everywhere and
there's poop everywhere and you have a
car with air conditioning yeah and
you're and they're like what is this
magical vehicle of you you must be a
king where you come from with this you
know it's like oh actually no I'm really
poor I'm late so bad it's really bad bad
and all their teeth have fallen out
they're all dead by 30 their babies are
dying and you're like yeah gangrene they
there's no it's like what you go back in
time and you're poor and you're hang out
the duty stops a stone goes whoop
stubbed my toe is it bleeding yep that's
it alright I guess I gotta I should cut
this toe off yeah yeah the base the base
line is different like our base level of
the standard of living that we are used
to is privileged yep everyone is I don't
care who you are I mean in America is
really was what I'm talking about
because this is this is obviously the
subject at hand you know it's like we
have air conditioning we have sewers
indoor plumbing yeah sewers oh yeah the
greatest force in ending poverty has
been mmm capitalism capitalism that's it
communism has only ever made more
poverty yeah a lot of people like Marx's
is responsible for over 200 million
people dying arguably higher right all
right now at least
200 million people have died because of
his ideologies it's weird that praise
you you're like we mentioned Jordan
Peterson in the past how he says we know
when the right goes too far
mm-hmm it is weird that we live in a
country that can't tell on the left has
gone too far and it clearly has but on a
lighter note Jordan Peterson has
resurfaced back thinked I'm glad you're
back Jordan yeah if you watch her show
horsey does okay someone someone was
like you should get Jordan on the show
and I'm like yes mr. Peters doctor
excuse me dr. Anderson we would lovingly
accept you on our show to enlighten us
and the star viewers yeah well you know
it you know I found it interesting what
when I first when I hit you up to do the
show before you were immersed in all
this political stuff yeah you had been I
guess you were reading and listening to
dr. Peterson yeah I was introduced to
him last year through one of nature's
friends and I the maps of meaning
basically and yeah it's if you don't
know it it's it's very enlightening
check it out it's the maps of meeting on
YouTube and it's it's basically one of
his theories or one of his classes and
you could just go watch it it's quite
long actually but absolutely worth it
you know it's about talks about what it
means to be human what we need our
purpose and what we're lacking nowadays
and he breaks it all down and gives
examples and it's it's really an
incredible watch so thanks for checking
out this clip from the Tim cast IRL
podcast we do the show live Monday
through Friday at 8 p.m. if you want to
catch the full show tune in to this
channel subscribe hit the like button or
check us out on iTunes and Spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you